احكينا يوسف كيف كانت الحياه قبل الحرب
والله كانت حياه يعني نوعا ما كانت حياه
فيها البعض او القليل من الرغد نقدر نقول
بما انه مستوانا المعيش الحمد لله يعني
كان من الناحيه المتوسطه و يعني كنا امنين
في بيوتنا في منازلنا نذهب الصباح الى
اعمالنا ننتهي من اعمالنا نذهب في نزهه مع
افراد العائله نجلس في حاراتنا امنين نضحك
نتسامر نلعب نلهو نتزاور ما بيننا البعض
ولكن الان انت ترى حالنا حال يرتى اليه
اصبحنا مشردين لا
نعرف ما هو القادم ما قد ذهب قد عرفناه
ولكن ما هو اتي لا نعرفه اليوم اصبحنا
مشردين في خيم والناس تناموا على الارض
تفترش بطنيات بسيطه تناموا على الارض
يستيقظون لا يعلمون مصيرهم ان كانوا احياء
او كانوا اموات يفقدون جيرانهم اصبحنا
ننام في قلق عميق جدا او نخاف من
الاستيقاض لكي نستمع الى احد مفقود او احد
قتل او الى بيت احدهم قد دمر او عمل فلان
قد ذهب فاصبحت
حياه اشبه بحياه القبور تكاد تكون
يعني